allons in Boise Idaho hey Alan how are
you Dave such an honor to talk to you
you saved our lives well I'm honored how
can I help here we got ourselves into a
situation we were working on our three
to six months of expending of the
expenses we paid off everything
including our house when Murphy slapped
silly and we ended up doing what we said
we'd never do and we went into our home
equity line of credit to the tune of
about $20,000 my question for you is do
we stay in tents and pay off this line
of credit or do we treat it kind of like
our house payment and start investing
and then just pay extra toward the thing
to get us out I stopped everything and
paid off immediately okay yeah I get it
get it done and then kick everything
back in hard core and then cancel the
line of credit don't leave it laying on
there so that it never grows back ever
ever ever again but it's it's not going
to take you long it's only 20,000 bucks
and you know how to do this you've done
it before
and just lean into it smash you know
smack it silly this time and let's get
rid of it and then build your emergency
fund up and you know having walked where
you walk you may want a bigger emergency
fund I don't know what happened that
caused that to happen and one of the
probability that situations ever there
again but I mean truthfully was Sharon
and I haven't been broke we've never
touched the emergency fund ever in their
lives because we're so paranoid
especially Sharon that we the emergency
fund has its own emergency fund and so
we never get to the real one we just
touched the outer ring if we ever got to
an emergency so we're just we're big big
piles of cash people because we don't
ever want to be back there again
we don't ever want to be back there
again